the yellow carpet premiere of the new
minion sequel that's where our will mar
fuji got gru himself steve carell
talking about his other movie sending
him and john krasinski back into the
office come here you come here you guys
spent so much time together almost a
decade ago and now you're working
together again now we're friends
best friends well i haven't started
working on the film with him yet but i
can't wait and i'm anticipating just joy
you just agree to that i can be very
surprising it will be a role reversal
from their days on the office john will
be in charge directing steve in
paramount's family film if it co-stars
ryan reynolds and is out in 2023. he's a
great director so i'll put him through
his paces you know i'll make him work
for it i might be one of those
persnickety actors won't come out of my
trailer no god yeah you think you hired
somebody that is a friend but you got
that wrong meantime steve returns as gru
in the origin story minions the rise of
grew out friday he is lovable and awful
at the same time how could you not like
that earlier steve and his minions got
cemented on the walk of fame i was
worried that he wouldn't be able to get
out of the cement it was so ridiculous i
couldn't help but laugh like what am i
what is happening
[Music]
you